[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 112 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Ock mandal and I'm here with my
colleague Melanie Warrick how are you
doing today Melanie hi mark I'm good
we've got a good podcast for us this
week we're gonna be talking to Mike
who's the co-founder and CEO of Persei
oh and they are doing visual diffs but
as always before we get into that we're
gonna do cool things the week and we're
gonna have a question at the end of the
week or at the end of the week at the
end of the end of the week we're going
to talk about if you wanted to know what
the news is of the week there's a nice
summary roundup and we're gonna point
you to where that is so before we get
into that let's talk about cool things
of the week yeah let's talk about cool
things of week I wanted to definitely
bring up a project that was announced
recently on the Google open source blog
project called open census which is a
stats collection and distributed tracing
framework we've probably talked about
this a little bit in some previous
episodes or at least those types of
things in previous episodes but this is
actually really cool it's an open source
project that is meant to be a trace and
metrics open source tool that will work
with a variety of backends and stats
providers and tracing things like Zipkin
or Prometheus or stack driver and a
bunch of other ones as well it's really
cool is coming out at Google we should
have them on the podcast soon which is
which we will but we will link to the
announcement blog post that has some
really pretty pictures about what can be
done with it as well as a medium
publication that is coming out of the
community from I hope I get this right
dad's Wilkin talking about using urban
census with Prometheus in stock driver
as well so you can see some code and
some of the stuff that people are
writing to use it with so I'm actually
really excited about open census so I
can't wait to have them on the episode
yes and it's also nice that it's
analysis tool agnostic yeah no I really
like that about the platform too so
another cool thing of the week that is
that the Zoological Society of London
has teamed up with Google and they're
using the cloud auto ml vision tool API
that we released and they're doing
basically facial recognition on
endangered species they're using a large
set of images that have been collected
from cameras in the wild they've had to
do a lot of manual labeling in the past
but with Auto ml vision they're working
on trying to make that more of course
automated and
apply models in essence to do facial
recognition and the intent is ultimately
to help with tracking endangered species
helping to reduce poaching I think their
goals for the future definitely to help
identify when there's injured animals if
you can help them so know that's kind of
a cool application of it ya know that's
really cool just thinking back from when
we were talking last week about
basically being able to train your
models without having to have a PhD or
something in machine learning that's a
really interesting application also I'm
just thinking about the fact that now
Google photos recognizes my dog as a
person it's very much understandable
well and then the last thing we wanted
to mention for the week is that one of
our colleagues Philippe Hoffman has done
a cool thing where he went to Melbourne
and he interviewed grand Polly from
shine tech who's a geg and they
basically did this cloud dataflow and
tram challenge where they were trying to
show that you can process about half a
terabyte of data and they had was it ten
point six billion rows of data while
they were traveling on the tram down to
Melbourne yep and they were doing this
so basically in ten minutes is what I
understood from that
yeah Graham has a track record of doing
these challenges on various different
types of public transport if he can do
things within the time frame with a cat
train or a tram goes from one place he's
gonna run out of public transport they
come to San Francisco and done it on a
trolley that needs to happen that
probably needs to happen but they do a
video and the video is really kind of
cool
so we'll post that up on our show notes
that's always well worth watching
awesome well why don't we go have a chat
with Mike from Percy and talk all about
visual continuous integration sounds
good
on this week's podcast we are joined by
Mike 14 Aki's who is a co-founder and
CEO of percy percy io and so percy is
actually this company that's focused on
visual discs so mike welcome to the
podcast thank you so much I'm really
thrilled to be here and Mike we'd like
you to tell us a little bit more about
yourself yeah absolutely um so yeah I'm
the CEO and co-founder of Percy and I
don't know what about me so I'm actually
an ex-googler too so I've been using
Google products for before they were
actually even called Google cloud
platform yeah and yeah I love love all
things software engineering and building
a team and the sort of cross-section
ality of things we like to say we work
on
like design development and deployment
so it's kind of like where I work is
that the intersection of those things
Thanks
and Percy Percy's this startup that
you've been working on for the last
couple years you're saying yeah that's
right yeah it started as a sort of side
project of mine of scratching my own
itch other company I used to work for
where we we were just launching visual
bugs all the time and this is sort of a
thing that has plagued my web
development of software engineering
career forever since since I was
actually like 10 years old and it's just
I finally finally got fed up with it and
I was like why isn't there somewhere
that just you can click a button and do
visual testing like why doesn't that
thing exist so I went off and tried to
build it and here we are and here we are
and so that's where that idea came from
and I think I read that it's perceptual
see I was what it was originally named
oh yes it was originally called
perceptual CI which probably makes sense
if you're an engineer and is terrible if
you're not so my best friend actually we
already had the masks out at the time
which you can see on our homepage is a
Percy the perceptual porcupine and the
color scheme is purple so a little bit
of alliteration the porcupine come from
I don't know it just alliterated with
and my best friend said why don't you
just call the thing Percy and I was like
oh well Percy dial was available at the
time so we grabbed it and you know the
rest is sort of history I spend a day
refactoring the code to get rid of all
the perceptual references and here we
are so okay so just so I get this
straight in my head right this is a
continuous integration system that
enables me to see UI bugs how does it
cui bugs how does that work yes
so Percy's entire goal is to really like
give you confidence in every visual
change you're making and even in changes
you're making that you might not think
are visual so there's a bunch of times
when like you're making a back-end
change and for some reason it like
manifests as a front-end bug and you
might not catch that if you're not you
know if doing QA on the front end if
you're not looking at specifically at
that page or figure relying on your own
memory to like remember what the page
looked like before this is why things
leak through to production all the time
right we just miss this stuff so yeah so
the way the percy approaches this
problem is to take a visual comparison
of what the state was before and then
what the state is after
the code change and we do this in a
truly continuous way so I like to say
we've sort of gotten through a couple
different iterations of these phrases
but I like to say continuous visual
validation or like continuous visual
integration so it's really meant to
bring the process of doing this as early
in the software development cycle as
possible so the goal and the way that
percy works is i should be able to make
a code change and then immediately look
at percy and see oh i effected nine
hundred pages and i didn't mean to i
only meant to affect one right and so
we'll show you is like a visual
comparison what we call a visual diff
and these these visual diffs are
basically just a comparison of two
different images without any context
necessarily about what the images are
about they're just like these pixels
have changed from from these pixels here
on the left and master to these pixels
here on the right in your pull request I
know when I've worked with github before
I mean I go and look at the disco Dan
what's change and I can see they do like
color coding and you can look from like
one side is what it was originally
versus the other side is what I've
changed so this is just it's that idea
but instead you're you're you're seeing
the actual visual representations of
every single page that's right and so
that's exactly what we we want to do in
the workflow process that we want to
allow like designers and engineers to
work through because you know you go to
github right now and you look on the
left and you look on the right and
you're like okay this code is changing
from this to this and code review gives
you a lot of nice benefits of like you
know catching bugs from your teammates
who can understand the code in the
architecture or they can say like oh
this you know you don't need to build it
this way we have this other system that
does that now you don't need that so you
get a lot of these benefits out of like
the code review process that aren't
necessarily like something you would
ever get from a static analysis tool
like a linter or something else and I
think the same exact workflow and
processes apply to visual testing like
you want to be able to say as a human
like yes these are the visual changes we
wanted like we wanted those visual
changes and whoops we didn't mean for
this one to change that page and like
that some you know that modal on that
page and that deep setting state on your
billing page changed and like you didn't
even mean to do that because you know
you weren't affecting that page and you
didn't look at it when you were making
the change so yeah we want to like give
you confidence that you know exactly
what you're changing in the same way
that a diff code diff gives you
confidence to know what you're changing
and your
application like your test Suites give
you confidence to know so if you're a
developer and you want to use percy how
does that look is this a tool that i run
locally is it something i can integrate
with the CI system like Travis or
Jenkins what can I do with it
yeah exactly so we integrate with CI
systems right now so what you do is you
plug Percy into like your test Suites
that you're already writing you have
these tests that I like visit this page
click these buttons do this thing or
like these components we want to test
these components in these States and you
integrate with your CI and then you push
up a pull request to github and then as
your CI runs it's pushing stuff to percy
and we've actually built a full like
rendering environment on top of Google
cloud platform that is this rendering
farm that's performing these renders in
the background doing these screenshots
and and handling all the weird edge
cases that go into that which we can
talk about and then we've just notate
the github PR and say hey there's 15
visual disks here that need to review
and that might be like right next to
your your green checkmark and github
that says 2,000 unit tests pass like
functionally everything is ready to go
you're you know you're great here but
then Percy catches it and says hey
you're about to launch some visual
changes do you want these visual changes
yes or no nice and then they can
basically go through and do that review
side to side and UNC and accept
accordingly yeah exactly so that's
that's that's a real goal is like give
you a visual review process like are you
like you are in the github with the
diffs between coding are you also able
to go in and directly inside the visual
make comments or say you know here's a
spot that you might miss or yeah that's
that's definitely on my roadmap it's not
something we do right now you can sort
of comment and github and say hey I
noticed this thing and Percy was was
wrong at the time or the week like you
changed this page and you didn't mean to
but yeah commenting and that kind of
like that's sort of it to the
intersectionality thing again like if we
can if we can help designers and
developers and PMS and I like facilitate
all of these workflows and you know you
can say like hey we need our p.m. to
like sign off on this change that's
totally something you should be doing on
the visual side of your site and like on
the changes that you're making at that
level so we we sort of have a pretty
basic workflow for that right now we try
to keep it really simple so you can just
iterate and improve things very easily
but more complex workflows are
definitely on the on the roadmap of
things we want to do awesome all right
so let's get under the hood yeah I want
to hear about how this thing actually
works
okay well I give a 45 minute tech talk
on it what do you like all right so I
guess probably the I'm guessing the most
interesting pot is the image analysis
part of it I'm willing to guess I don't
know sure why how does that work I'm
guessing that's a fairly computationally
intensive workload well okay so yeah a
lot of it is pretty computationally
intensive but it's probably not the part
that you expect is is computationally
intensive so basically in the talk that
I give I basically show you like what is
a visual dip in the first place like
what is a visual dip and I just show you
two images and then a visual dip is just
like the difference between these it's
the comp like computationally what is
the difference what's the delta between
these two images so like it's basically
a transparent PNG with red pixels on it
and the red pixels tell you which pixels
have changed between the two states so
like these pixels have changed between
these two states so generating those
visual diffs is actually one of the
cheapest parts of the process okay you
can literally run like an image magic
compare command give it two images and
give it a diff output and then you open
up the diff and that's the difference
and you can apply a bunch of like
translucency and effects and stuff like
all as deep as you can go into image
magic there and or bevels like gradient
rewrite this and go as your own like PNG
interpreter things like you'd do it
would you could do whatever you want the
hard part about this system and the part
that we all rely a lot on like our own
infrastructure and on GCP to do and to
scale for is the actual rendering of the
screenshots so there's a bunch of
problems that come along with with
rendering screenshots partially because
browsers are just super complicated
nowadays right like browse the source
code for Chrome I think is as large or
almost as large as the Linux kernel now
like it's just it's massive and so these
things like we want to keep browsers
developing we want to keep them really
modern but they come along with all of
these like rendering different
differences for example like the simple
and you can think of as like animations
it's like what happens if an animation
is on a page well if you take a visual
divot you might get just a random frame
of the animation as like compared to the
previous random frame of the animation
so what we do in percy for example is we
like freeze the CSS of the page or the
CSS animations of the page we inject
some CSS that
tries to aggressively turn off all of
those animations so that we can freeze
them in a particular state or like we
freeze animated gifts so that they don't
progress through their animation so
we're just looking at the first frame so
we can make these these renders really
deterministic that's the easy one in a
lot of ways the harder ones are like did
you know that GPUs don't actually
guarantee that like if you divide two
numbers they will be the same answer in
the end you know it's like things like
that where if you compile software with
different optimization flags you might
get GPUs might execute the instructions
differently so like if you're rendering
a gradient on one machine if it's like a
GPU rendered gradient and you render
that exact same gradient on another
machine they might not be pixel
perfectly accurate or like it a little
bit of an easier one so fonts if you if
you upgrade this the fonts of the system
that you're working on you might get
weird like anti aliasing artifacts
around the edges of the fonts if chrome
decides to like make the rendering
better which they do all the time then
like you might get weird
anti-aliasing artifacts are like weird
like edges of different tiles or just
improved rendering overall or like a new
CSS feature so so one of the big parts
of what we do at Persie is we try to
handle this process for you and give you
like a really deterministic rendering
environment that handles all of the
complexities of visual testing so for
example we like freeze the fonts of the
system and handle this in a
containerized way we freeze the
animations on the pages we handle the
browser upgrade and process for you and
try to keep everything modern under the
stack so the sort of naive solution to
this is I'm running my CI system and I
just tell it like hey render me a
screenshot and put it to disk or like
you know put it in some artifact
directory and and keep the screenshots
across the the CI runs that's kind of
how the first iteration of firstly
actually started right was I mean we're
running at Jenkins install and it's just
like dumping screenshots and running
diffs and then you know you kind of like
can sort of tell what's what's happening
there if you do that then what happens
is you'll you'll end up generating a
bunch of screenshots that end up being
slightly different over time and for
reasons that you can't actually control
and then so that's one so like
determinism is like the big problem and
then the other second big problem is
performance it can take 15 20 30 seconds
to like tell the browser to actually
render a full page PNG of
the image so if you end up doing a
hundred of those in a CI run which is
not that many UI states you might add
thirty minutes to your test suite which
nobody wants to do and it's kind of like
a horrible thing which I think this
performance is like the big big reason
why visual testing is not something that
every engineering team is doing right
now
so the way that percy handles that is by
just making it completely out-of-band of
your CI suite we add basically no
overhead to your CI suite at all because
all we do is we send up these Dom
snapshots we capture the state of the
page that you've rendered in your
testing environment so like you know you
have a test that visits on page clicks a
drop down and the JavaScript is executed
and you know chrome headless or
something so then we take the Dom State
of that page along with the development
assets around it send them up to Percy
and then render them in our custom
rendering farm so that allows us to
number one parallel eyes the entire
thing aggressively so we can finish very
quickly and really like truly live up to
our our goal of being continuous and
then two it allows us to like control
for all of these variables where you you
know can't really deal with those
rendering differences in your like CI
environment and you wouldn't really want
to so that that sort of model in that
architecture has given us a lot of
flexibility to really make first see try
to live up to this this like continuous
part of our goal and really bring this
process really early on in the software
development lifecycle cool I have so
many questions let's start with like
what is like what's the Google cloud
platform products they're using here you
mentioned containers like sort of buried
the lead there a little bit about it
sounds like that's maybe how you're
running the actual browsers I'm not sure
but like what's that what does that flow
look like through the products as you go
so yeah we've been using Google cloud
platform from the beginning for
everything and actually percy grew up in
a world where containers were already
existing in some ways I sort of dealt
with like early early docker bugs and
like that sort of that early pain there
but glad that we we sort of bet on that
early on because that has just allowed
us to to scale this infrastructure so
much more easily had we done something
else so yeah so everything is
containerized and that's how our fold
deployment pipeline works and how like
we update our rendering environments is
pushing these new containers and pushing
new versions we just recently actually
graded off of I don't know if you even
remember like container - BMS oh yes so
before google kubernetes engine even it
was like a version of kubernetes that
kind of ran on a single node and didn't
tell you it was kubernetes but just had
to get like a ya know file you could
give and run a set of containers on a
single node so we moved off of that to a
full google kubernetes engine also thank
you for renaming it - it makes a lot
more sense now and yeah so GK is Benna
is now a big part of our workflow it's
enabled us to get to continuous
deployment really quickly and we are
actually doing that now where as of just
a month or two ago we've all of our
things are continuously deployed and
we've sort of moved into that world very
quickly as we've been able to adopt more
kubernetes features cool so let me I'm
just trying to work through the flow so
you say they have a dumb upload yeah
where does that go
so so yeah [ __ ] you through the cycle so
a Dom snapshot gets uploaded to Percy we
figure out like okay what what browsers
do you want to render this in because
it's a Dom snapshot we can also like
resize the browser to where the dumps to
actually go though Oh Google Cloud
Storage so we we started in Google Cloud
storage and then if you think about it
like we actually have to reload we have
to reconstruct the state of the page
that you've had in your test environment
perfectly in our environment so what we
have to do is start up Chrome for
example or Firefox and run a proxy there
to actually say like oh you were loading
localhost something index.html great we
have that over here in Google Cloud
Storage we proxy all of these assets
using a proxy that we've written and go
and then we like load up chrome running
in one of these containers and we render
the page we proxy all of your
development assets as well so like we
have to do this right because the we're
not rendering live sites here right
we're rendering stuff that's in NCI in
development like it's really early in
the process so we need to be able to
like access and run things that are your
your like development assets that came
from your test suite so we can't just
rely on the fact that your your assets
might exist in production somewhere and
like you might have a CSS file sitting
you know a live accessible so we proxy
all of the assets including the raw Dom
snapshot that you gave us and
potentially like resize the browser and
do a bunch of different sizes that you
might have specified to say we care
about this page on mobile on desktop on
you know tablet sizes and render those
screenshots do the image magic you know
comparison to the actual diffs upload
those Google Cloud storage and then yeah
this is all sort of the back end is all
like a rails API to that's sort of
orchestrating some of this some of this
process and then we also have a like
Redis queue that's that's helping sell
or facilitate some of the pieces to are
you running kubernetes jobs for this or
your own sort of batch queue process our
own batch queue process yep mm-hmm
yeah we it's actually great to see sort
of this sort of platform effects of
different providers just we like use
Redis labs for our our Redis provider
and they just have a GCP option so
decide gzp put it into the same zone
we're close to great we have a Redis
host we don't have to manage Redis for
so we do that with quite a bit of our
stuff and we use Google Cloud sequel
which has been really great yes sort of
also it's all like my sequel five seven
or whatever the latest one is there and
yeah it's been it's been really good and
you said you also using Sto yes so we
recently over the last year we've sort
of migrated from heavily using the
Google cloud HTTP load balancer to
running our own layer seven load
balancing stack so why good question it
was sort of driven from a lot of things
we wanted to do more like traffic
splitting experiments we want to be able
to like canary releases a little bit
easier the Google cloud load balancer is
really great and like very performant
overall but there there were some
features in there that we started having
some issues with that we wanted to like
be able to have full control over so for
example like we want to be able to
internally retry post requests if if
like they fail which the Google cloud
load balancer only retries get requests
right and was actually that was
undocumented at the time too I sort of
just only knew that because I was an
ex-googler and it's like oh I know that
this load balancer like retries get
requests but will never retry post
requests because they're not idempotent
right so yeah we we wanted to sort of
have more control over that and then as
as per season infrastructure gets more
and more complex we have more and more
micro services that sort of fall out and
like draw a boundary around that service
to say oh that that makes
senses the micro-service so we wanted to
be able to sort of control the internal
our pcs and and how like things are
flowing throughout the system and how we
can or we can orchestrate that stuff and
as our development team grows give them
more ability to like just change one
part of the service rather than changing
a huge monolith so since you're from
Google or an ex-googler is that why you
went with JCP to begin with that was
part of it I think a lot of it is
because it started as a side project of
mine too so I was like heavily
optimizing for costs in some ways and so
you know my my favorite Google Cloud
product is actually the Google cloud
pricing calculator I know that sounds
crazy but that's it just gives you so
much visibility as somebody who is like
paying for it out of my own bank account
at the time to say like oh I will know
exactly I'm gonna spend that this month
on this thing and so as we were sort of
bootstrapping it early on that's that
was gave me a lot of confidence to know
and and also because I knew that this
needed to scale like I knew that it just
needed to be able to if you're gonna
have something that can be truly
continuous for everyone's workflow it
has to be horizontally scalable you have
to just be able to say oh you need two
million snapshots a month great here's a
bunch of workers and renderers for you
like you just need that ability of based
on the Dom snapshot any model that we
have so so I sort of bet on Google cloud
platform there because yeah it just made
a lot of sense for the infrastructure
that we needed and the scalability that
we needed and also as an excuse or like
I knew how good Google's like networking
technologies are for example and just
like how world-class that is like more
than most people know right like you
it's just really good
so just Betty did not feed that actually
not a Google cloud rep of your ice
Cream's coming later it's that's great
so so what well actually let me ask then
it would have been some of the
challenges you've hit up against by
using TCP well let me flip that question
a little bit so like kubernetes fills in
a lot of the gaps right like if you want
to run your own infrastructure in like
orchestrate it if you if you can sort of
like get through the learning curve if
you can like understand the aminal
understand all the pieces like what
you're pointing at what things then all
of a sudden you can run your own
infrastructure as a service and not have
a full time DevOps person doing it and
managing
every day or like a team so it's given
us a lot of flexibility in that way
because you know we actually could if we
needed to we could move off of Google
cloud quickly because all of these
pieces are sort of cloud agnostic and I
know that plays into sort of Google's
like you know want to really make this
stuff high quality and make it so you
don't feel like cloud lock-in and like
all of this stuff so so yeah we some of
the challenges I guess yeah getting
visibility into some of the like deeper
inner features of like what's happening
inside of like the load balancer and
that kind of stuff can be kind of
challenging sometimes that's that's the
biggest one I can think of well and so
in terms of where the products going and
what can you share with us in terms of
your plans for the future outside of you
know you'd mentioned before about
wanting to be able to directly edit
inside of the visual deaths yeah so if
you if you think about it
Persis is all about workflow it's it's
nice to be able to say like oh we like
hot a visual bug like oh we had this
visual bug that kept happening on our
homepage and we got percy and we fixed
that we never launched we're never gonna
launch that visual bug again great like
visual regressions are a big part of
like what drives people to adopt visual
testing but the the long-term goal is
all about like facilitating more and
more of those workflows right like what
other pieces can we can we pull out and
sort of automate away from the things
that the software delivery lifecycles is
doing right now so if you think about it
like there's a big there's a big gap
between I've created a pull request
somebody is reviewing it and I'm merging
it to like production right and that gap
can be a bunch of things it can be your
deployment processes like continuous
deployment if you can get there like
really helps close that gap quite a bit
but one of the big glass pieces that we
just haven't automated at all if for
some reason like this just didn't exist
was the ability to say like yes I have
full confidence to know what visual
changes are going out as part of this
release or as part of this commit and so
that's really what we want to do is like
every every piece around like confidence
around the deployments and around those
steps is is what we're aiming to do so
you can imagine like you could have you
could have comments on the on the visual
disks you could say oh this this
particular part is is broken you could
collaborate you could say hey are the
designer on our team she needs to go
check this out and like see why that's
why that's broken no we're like yeah we
have a bunch of stuff on the roadmap
there well and I can imagine
- I know with machine learning and the
rise of machine learning that the actual
UI is constantly being built to be
flexible to change to be very just not
to hard-coded jørgen with so I just zoom
that you're also constantly thinking
about like if you're gonna do you know
continue to grow the visual diffs like
how that will adapt as the UI changes
yeah absolutely so machine learning and
computer vision can be a big part of
what we can do to automate this stuff in
the future right like there's also a big
hard problem there which is how do you
know if a visual change is correct or
not and that's a human part right
because you can say as a human like yeah
that I meant to change that from this to
this or no I didn't but getting
computers to understand intent like that
is is a pretty difficult problem so I
can see us going there over time as we
gather more data around like people are
approving things that look like this or
they've hinted to us that like this is
the appropriate visual change or we know
that this change looks like all of these
other changes and therefore it's also
okay and Google cloud like has a bunch
of computer vision API is like things
like that that we might be able to
leverage to get closer to that kind of
goal where we're presenting to you the
most relevant changes like here are the
most relevant visual changes for you and
try to like knock down the the amount of
potential like noise or the potential
for like just an overload of data
because you want these these visual
reviews to be as small as possible and
it's like as targeted as possible in a
lot of ways and on a different note I I
know when we were talking before we
started recording I was saying how I'd
be curious to hear and just send a
little bit of a side note what it was
like I mean you said you woke up one day
and you had the idea for Percy but he
didn't just snap your fingers and you
had a company I'd assume unless you did
and that's pretty impressive what was it
like what can you tell us a little bit
about what it was like going from I've
got the idea - you know now I'm actually
running a company yeah absolutely it
sort of started as like is is this a
project is this a business how big is
the opportunity here those kinds of
questions and I had decided early on to
sort of bootstrap the company and and
see how far I can take it and and and
get some get some just validation around
like okay do people feel this pain is
this just a pain I was feeling was this
the pain everyone feels and so when I
started realizing that like there's
really no
that doesn't have this problem right
like it doesn't matter what your tech
stack is it doesn't matter really what
what product you're building if you're
on the web or if you're on mobile or if
you're building something that users are
touching or looking at like you have
visual needs and so then my co-founder
Tim and I joined forces and we were like
okay let's take this as a real
opportunity to build a company around
this and that's just been such a
thrilling process for me because this is
my first company and thankfully tim has
a lot more experience in that way we're
both engineers by trade but he's on
multiple companies now so it's good to
have him as sort of my rock in that way
to help me sort of realize like what's
important and what's not as we go
through our day-to-day and yeah it's
been it's been a great experience to
sort of see like even though or you know
we're still a small team that we can
really execute really quickly and that
that actually matters to our customers
quite a bit so you know if you're if
you're a solo solo person working on it
you just only have so much bandwidth to
do like address customer needs to do
sales to do marketing to do to do
conference talks to do all the pieces of
it and actually really build the like
machine around like getting getting the
the info out there so so yeah getting
getting more help in building the team
around it and really realizing that you
know people are inspired by this problem
it's it's a hard thing to solve but when
you realize that like you know you just
you just saved an hour and then you just
saved another hour and you just saved
another hour like every every time
you're making these changes it's such a
drastic shift in the way that even our
own team develops our own software we
have a designer who just joined us
recently and you know he's using if he
does a redesign of like a certain part
of the app or a certain way that we're
you know like the header or something on
the app we have full confidence that we
know exactly what is changing and Percy
every time we changed the app so he was
like he was making this really big CSS
refactor the other day was adding all
this like really modern CSS stuff things
that I didn't even know existed and and
I was like this is great and also I
don't have to even look at this too
carefully in some ways because we know
with confidence exactly what pixels are
going to change at the end of this so we
use percy as our own sort of like dog
fooding to like know exactly what we're
on we're changing in our own application
and it's it saved us a bunch of times
we're like
on the billing page we were like gonna
lose a button that was really important
that needed to be there all the time and
it was just gone once because of some
change and you know you catch that
before it even reaches your customers so
that kind of stuff has been really fun
to see as we built the company side of
it like that
our customers have those same problems
have the same issues no matter what
their text sack what their sort of
environment if they if they care about
the design or like the stability of
their application at all then they care
about the visual side of their sites so
yeah that's really been a really
thrilling experience and I also have
learned that I like I love wearing
multiple hats all the time and sort of
switching between them it can be very I
don't know like a lot of emotional
overhead can go into being the founder
which is something that I'm learning and
sort of anticipating so it's a lot of
like emotional context switching you
need to be able to be be in a meeting at
once that's sort of like a drag or it's
like really hard and then you need to
move to the next meeting and be really
happy and you need to move the next
meeting and like not say that one thing
or you know it's just like emotional
context switching over and over and over
so it can be thrilling it if you have
the right team behind you and really
like inspired to work on the product and
really make it better cool well we are
running out of time just a little bit
but before we go is there anything we
haven't mentioned or something you want
to plug or an event you're gonna be at
or anything cool that's going on that
you want to make sure you mention before
you run away yeah you can you can always
contact us we have a little intercom
button on our site feel free to reach
out and say hey we were think about you
you know I'm checking out very visual
testing for this thing and we're happy
to chat we're also gonna be up at ember
conf
in Portland in March I can't I think
it's March 11th and 12th something with
somewhere around check it out put in
June it's great and yeah we'll be up
there we'll have a booth we'll be
talking to people and we're sort of
always around and we're in San Francisco
in the area in case anyone wants to come
by and chat about this it's a pretty
early team pretty early problem in a lot
of ways we have a lot of traction in
that way and are excited about the
future great well we're so glad you
joined us this is great to hear by Percy
and how you're solving problem solving
the QA process with a visual disk so
thank you so much thank you guys so much
thanks thanks Mike that was great to
talk to you about what percy is doing
and also to learn a little bit about how
we can look at visual diffs and do QA
around visual tips I definitely think
that's a helpful tool to have now mark
question of the week if I want something
to read because I don't have enough to
read right now but I need something
that's gonna summarize the news for me
for the week cuz there's a lot you've
got going on where do I go one of our
teammates I'm gonna totally massacre
last name he's a developer relations
program manager he manages a bunch of
our internal programs here at Google
that work with a bunch of different
people outside of Google as well great
fellow Alexi oh my god Alexi machine
pushkin it's probably actually Spurlin
about I think that's good I think
that'll there anyway he does a weekly
medium publication that I thought it
would be worth mentioning
strangely enough cold this week in
Google cloud platform where he basically
does little summaries of what's happened
in the past week giving you sort of
titles and little descriptions on what's
going on and he also does this picture
of the week showing a little snapshot of
what something interesting somebody has
done on Google cloud platform so if
you're looking for something sort of
weekly that sort of doesn't I summary
and sort of ends up in your feed or on
your medium feed you know once a week is
for cool things of the week you should
check that we will definitely have links
in the show notes
all right well mark I think that wraps
it up for us for this week you know
you're off soon you're off to London I'm
in London as we speak this will be it as
this comes off you'll be in London we
don't pre-record this at all yep
I'm in London as we speak and you are
also me in San Francisco yeah still just
going nuts Game Developers Conference in
March and I'll be at FOSDEM am I saying
that right it's it's FOSDEM or I don't
know fuzz damn let's bust em that's who
I'm gonna be how else would you
pronounce it pho is dim this weekend
that's basically in Brussels wonderful
alright well Melanie thank you so much
for joining me for yet another episode
thanks mark I think you will for
listening and we'll see you all next
week
[Music]